[Musique]
comme le cosmos en ce temps-là et héron
les marins shadoks croyant débarquer
chez les jib y ont débarqué chez eux
voler leurs propres fusées et sont
repartis au bout d'un certain temps
naturellement il re débarquèrent chez
eux
mais comme il faisait encore un peu nuit
ils retournèrent se coucher en attendant
d'être reçus triomphalement les shadoks
voyant leurs fusées revenus criaient
victoire victoire note refusé march et
les parcs qui tout seul
elle est revenu tout seul et il
s'empressèrent de l'art transporter de
l'autre côté pour concéder un continent
à de nouveaux essais les marins en se
réveillant crièrent à l'abordage à
l'abordage les ribinou trahis ils ont
repris leurs fusées et il repartir
aussitôt pour bâcher et du fab sans dire
que la chose duras comme ça pendant
assez longtemps
et pendant que c'est pitoyable bestioles
tourner tant qu'on l'egypte y cultivait
tranquillement leur jardin et récoltait
des graines du sinn pour les emmener sur
la terre quand ils plantaient d'une
graine du sinn la terre se transformer
petit à petit on ce qu'il fallait que
tout cela se relier où se relier pas
selon ce qui est écrit dans la graine
est au bout de temps autant de saisons
elle donnait selon les cas me des
bananes des montres suisses des noix de
coco des barres de fer ou des bulldozer
mais un moment l'egypte y s'arrêter
écrié c'est long et shadow oxelo de ce
dock il courait au bord de la planète
pour les voir passer mais un jour
malheureusement le jeu c'est ça les
shadoks ne passèrent pas et les gibiers
était un peu triste car il commençait à
s'y attacher qui étaient devenus les
pauvres marin shadoks
[Musique]